as you mentioned uh
in the minds of some Americans after 9
11 the religion of Islam was associated
with
maybe you could say evil in the world
yeah maybe you can say uh terrorism uh
how can you respond to this Association
how does it make you feel first of all
as a devout Muslim yourself and
um how can you overcome it personally
how can you overcome it as a community
and as a religious leader
it's interesting because 911 now we're
talking over 21 years ago
you know there's people born after 9 11.
it's great to get to talk to them all
the time yeah so when I'm talking to
Young Muslims I'm talking about Post 9
11 Post 9 11 they're like I didn't I was
born in 2005. what are you talking about
post 911 I'm like well you know I
remember being a teenager I remember
being in high school when this happened
right so a lot of us that experienced
911 as high school lures or as college
students and remember distinctly what it
was like to be a Muslim pre-911 and Post
9 11 we can relate to that experience
and we could we could identify that
juncture you know very clearly and talk
about it and speak to the change in the
perceptions of Islam that happened here
in the United States and around the
world but a lot of young people are born
into that reality and are experiencing
the aftermath of it
and um you know unfortunately have to
deal with the bigotry that has uh not
just you know taken greater shape in
media constructions of Islam but also
policies right a lot of the civil
liberties of the Muslim Community uh
were taken away from us you read about
the Patriot Act you read about the
securitization of the Muslim Community
and some of the unfair practices that
have been engaged by the Bush
Administration the Obama Administration
the Trump Administration and continue
into the Biden Administration uh
International islamophobia and so
the hatred of Muslims and the bigotry
that is wielded against
Muslims on the basis of this idea that
we are a barbaric people not
ascribed to a religion of hate and
violence
um has had immediate consequences for us
no matter where we are in terms of our
age and uh in terms of our experience we
We have dealt with that in different
ways now
the association of Islam to terrorism is
a lazy Association
it's one that ignores both
The History of Violence
as well as its everyday occurrence
you know we're good for how many mass
shootings a year
once when's the last time you heard of a
Muslim carrying out a mass shooting in
America right how many of those mass
shootings if you were to scrub the
social media what 400 500 mass shootings
a year
if you were to scrub the social media of
some of those that carried out those
shootings you know we're good for one or
two idiots a year right you know it's
unfortunate that you're gonna have
people that uh that carry out despicable
acts of violence
but when we as Muslims hear someone in
the media say terrorism has been ruled
out as a possibility
while the blood is still on the floor of
that Walmart we already know that the
police chief just said that that wasn't
a Muslim don't worry you know there was
no Akai the guy or an Isis guy it was it
was one of our own right and so it's
it's become
frankly ridiculous because the
association of violence with Islam
uh is one that is used to actually uh
carry out acts of violence against
Muslims worldwide it justifies bad
policy towards Muslims worldwide and
then in the United States and it's just
factually so lazy there was a study just
about how the media gives more attention
to acts of violence done by Muslims and
immediately uh stamps it with Islam up
to 300 percent more than it will with
another act of violence carried out in
the name of anything else so you don't
hear about the acts of violence that are
carried out by others you don't hear
about the religion of the perpetrators
you don't associate terrorism with
actions frankly of State terrorism you
know when governments launch chemical
attacks or drone weddings
and do so while explicitly dehumanizing
the people just because they do so
with the government apparatus doesn't
make it any less terroristic than if
it's a lone person that goes out and
commits an act of violence trying to
achieve a political goal
so the association is lazy historically
speaking the Crusades I grew up in
Louisiana I saw Clan rallies ku klux
klan rallies my whole life and people
said well that's a thing of the past
well guess what you know we see many
semblances many acts that are carried
out with the same vitriol that was
generated by the Ku Klux Klan
we have people standing in front of our
mosques that belong to right wing hate
militias carrying
AR-15s talking about wanting to inflict
harm on Muslims I have been to
Christchurch New Zealand and buried the
victims of a white supremacist terrorist
who was inspired by the political
rhetoric here in the United States in
his own words in his Manifesto to go and
kill 50 innocent people in Christchurch
New Zealand one of the most peaceful
cities in the world
and by the way Lex I mean it's really
interesting like with Christ Church
you know the man wanted and I won't even
say his name
but his next Target after the two
mosques had he not been stopped was to
go to a Muslim daycare so what drives
someone
to dehumanize people to that extent that
he was willing to go to a daycare and
murder a bunch of kids because he saw
them as a demographic threat to
civilization so Muslims are terrorized
because they are falsely depicted as
terrorists Muslims suffer domestically
and globally because of this false
Association It's a lazy Association
and when someone comes around and says
well
fine not all Muslims are terrorists but
all terrorists are Muslims I say that
you clearly don't read statistics
whether we're talking about the 20th
century and I'm a student of history and
I believe you are as well all the isms
World War One World War II had nothing
to do with religion certainly nothing to
do with Islam fascism uh Soviet atheism
right many of these systems where people
were murdered in the millions Nazism uh
the Holocaust Rwanda Cambodia I can go
on and on the rohingya Today the
greatest atrocity towards the oyers
where is Islam fit in all of this people
do horrible things
they stamp it with religion at times
but the only group of people that seem
to suffer after an act of violence is
committed are Muslims because any act of
violence that is committed by a Muslim
will immediately be blamed on Islam and
two billion people will have to carry
the burden of the act of a single
perpetrator
and
just to reiterate
in case the numbers are not known you
mentioned Christ Church those are two
mosque shootings
oh 51 people killed and 40 were injured
in New Zealand yeah
so it's uh
it's hate manifesting itself and and
then uh actual human suffering and
destruction
absolutely is there similarities between
uh anti-Semitism and anti-muslim Hate
so is there something deeper to say
about hate in general here that is
beyond just particularly hate towards
Muslims absolutely look
um in Pittsburgh the synagogue shooting
the perpetrator particularly targeted
target targeted that
synagogue because Tree of Life synagogue
Tree of Life synagogue 11 killed six
wounded in 2018.
because
he believed that they were taking in
Syrian refugees or supporting Syrian
Muslim refugees
you think about that
the San Diego synagogue shooting that
took place shortly after he went to a
mosque and then he went to a synagogue
um
look the idea of
scapegoating minority populations
and attributing to them
a disproportionate sense of power and a
nefarious element where they can't be
trusted
and unless we wipe them out
then they're going to wipe us out
underlies many of the bigotries that
exist I mean look um after Trump
announced his Muslim ban there was a
shooting in Canada
an attack in Canada on a mosque in
Quebec where six people were killed
the shooter explicitly said that the
reason why he went to that mosque in
Quebec and shot dead six Muslim
worshipers was because he was afraid
that because of the ban on Syrian
refugees in the United States they would
come to Canada and he didn't want them
to feel welcomed in Canada
so so there is a connection
and I think it's when you are able to
dehumanize large groups of people
and attribute a nefarious element to
them
then unfortunately in a world that's
becoming more and more polarized where
people are able to construct their
entire world views
based on an algorithm
that their social media caters to
you're going to have
some of these attacks happen and there's
going to be an unfortunate connection
between them
so what I what I tell people is that you
know I think with all of these people
that shoot up synagogues and shoot up
mosques and even before that actually
the
Charleston South Carolina shooting at an
AME Church
you know
when he went there
he actually said that before he murdered
nine worshipers in that church
he was taken aback by how nice they were
to him he sat there for two hours before
he turned a gun on
many people who were over the age of 80
years old
and murdered Them In Cold Blood
so this is what I talk about when I say
that as human beings we have the
propensity unfortunately
to become worse than Devils or we can
choose
to be angelic
when we choose worship and righteousness
over ourselves
so that's a spiritual crisis as well and
a crisis of meaning and emptiness
where I think
people are willing to inflict great pain
on others when they can't make sense of
their pain in their own lives
I'd like to try to figure out together
with you sort of um
a way out
to try to decrease the amount of hate in
the world but maybe it's useful to talk
about the BBC documentary that
um it's kind of interesting that people
should check out it's called United
States of hate Muslims under attack and
you um you appear in that you have
conversations with people who are uh
anti-muslim and it's I believe most of
it takes place here in Dallas yeah and
can you just tell me about this uh
little documentary about that time what
it was like to interact what was the
group in the documentary and what was
like to interact with them you know in
the very beginning of um the rise
of at that time actually Ted Cruz Donald
Trump like when when islamophobia
uh was at the center of many of the
presidential candidates campaigns at the
time so this must have been 2015 yes
2015.
um the mayor of Irving at the time Beth
Van Dyne who is now a congresswoman
had put out the idea
that Muslims were operating at Sharia
Court in Irving Texas
and suddenly there was hysteria because
again there's the idea that Muslims are
here to dominate Muslims are here to
overthrow everything that you have
um in the United States there was a
hysteria here
and it was unfortunate because
um what it Unleashed
you know especially with the national
discourse at the time again the
presidential campaign you know Donald
Trump says I think Islam hates us
when he uses those words I think Islam
hates us
when Ted Cruz suggests that Muslim
neighborhoods could be patrolled or
should be patrolled
and then you have the Irving mayor
saying that one of the most populated
cities with Muslims in America they're
operating under an alternative legal and
Alternate legal system and
funny enough the year before that she'd
come to the mosque and she praised the
diversity of Irving and she was talking
about how welcome she felt in the mosque
and the next thing we know you have
these crazy white supremacist groups
openly white supremacists that affiliate
themselves with
the clan and others
protesting regularly in front of our
mosques with their AR-15s
and
um telling people to go back home and
I'm like I'm from New Orleans I'm not
planning to move back to New Orleans I'm
home we're we're home we're good you
know we're staying put
and we refuse to be intimidated
um but then when the Syrian refugee
crisis is unfolding as well
Dallas has been one of the more popular
destinations if you will I'm not talking
about it like a vacation destination but
where a lot of refugees have come to
just because of the infrastructure that
we have set up here
to receive refugees
and so that hysteria
was an unfortunate perfect combustion of
the national discourse with the local
discourse with the incoming refugees
and we would do all sorts of Welcome
Refugee events and we do that you know
and and we don't only do that for Muslim
refugees by the way there are refugees
from other parts of the world as well
um but we would host events at our
mosques you know to welcome refugees to
help integrate them into the community
to do things for them so you have these
armed protests happening right and it's
horrible because
I think about the trauma to the children
that are hearing about tree of life and
hearing about some of these other
incidents that are unfolding and really
one of the first communities I was
targeted was the Sikh community in
Madison that was one of the first
shootings and then the AME Church
Charleston
and then you just had tons of places of
worship being targeted right so they're
seeing this unfold and they're seeing
these guns in front of their mosques and
the result
to many as well I just don't want to get
shot I don't want to go to the mosque I
don't want to have this happen to me
so I you know and BBC reached out and
said we want to do a documentary about
this uh unfortunately Dallas was the
only place in America where you had
regular armed groups in front of our
mosques it was happening around the
country infrequently but here it was
happening every week so the BBC reached
out and said we want to interview you I
said we've got this idea we want to put
you we want to take you to a park and
have you meet one of the protesters
uh who's been wielding his gun outside
your mosque and talked to him
and it was really interesting because
they'd interviewed him before meeting me
and the things that he was able to utter
before meeting me and before meeting
Syrian refugees
uh was just awful I mean the most
dehumanizing rhetoric that you can
imagine
but then at the park
he meets me talks to me he meets a
Syrian refugee family
one of the girls whose leg had been
blown off in an airstrike
and he said I feel like an idiot I mean
he expressed all sorts of regret
and was teary-eyed
that he could dehumanize people the way
that he was and so my whole thing was
and is come inside the mosque put your
gun down
disarm yourself and learn
and you'll be surprised what you'll walk
away with
and only took one meeting with him
um so completely
uh shift
his worldview at the time
which
was made up of heroes and villains the
Muslims unfortunately being the villains
that had to be wiped off the face of the
Earth so that the Earth could continue
so that was uh that was an interesting
documentary and it was an interesting
social experiment
what's it feel like to have
all these
people that hate you
and others in the community people you
love
um with guns
threatening violence
basically that we don't want you here in
this country on this Earth
um
it's not nice it's not great I mean it's
um
it's definitely a challenge but look
there are challenges that we face as as
Muslims
um being in the United States being in a
hostile climate there are different
types of challenges and uh I think what
we've had to do as a Muslim Community
is see beyond both the guns and the
roses and think about who we are first
because frankly
uh
islamophobia exists in different forms
and from different sides
and we try to use this as an opportunity
to instill in our young people
not just the sense of belonging but a
sense of purpose
ah
do not be intimidated
and in fact show them the best of your
Islam live your life because at the end
of the day
the goal that is sought through
intimidation is silence
and so we have to carry ourselves as
proud American Muslims we don't have to
impress anyone
and we don't need to relinquish an iota
of our faith
to coexist with anyone we are satisfied
with who we are we don't we don't see a
contradiction
between
our place of residence and our religion
our nationality our religion we don't
see that as a problem right so that's a
that's something for them to work out
not for you to work out that's what I
would tell young Muslims that continue
to live your faith fully and demonstrate
the beauty of it and do not let the
ugliness of the world consume you
but for those young Muslims what would
you say how they should feel towards the
people that hate them
the natural human
there's a desire still to have anger to
have
resentment to have hate back at the
people that hate you
the Quran says respond to that which is
evil with that which is better and you
will find that
sometimes your enemy will become your
close friends
so respond with that which is better
doesn't mean be passive sometimes there
needs to be a demonstration of strength
sometimes there needs to be a
demonstration of uh ignoring a people
altogether
But ultimately you can't let the way
people treat you shape who you're going
to be in the world
and so that's why I say we have to look
beyond the guns on the Roses we have to
look Beyond
the hostility of our enemies and the
temporary and opportunistic embrace of
some of those claim to be our allies
and be us and treat the world and treat
the people of this world in accordance
with your standards
not with theirs so don't teach them
you know or don't let them teach you bad
character you teach them good character
so live your life and and live your
faith beautifully
and let people see the beauty of it
through your through your being and do
not let their ugliness
consume you but at the same time
sometimes you got to give people room to
express frustration to to say that this
is unacceptable to have demonstrations
of strength
and I think that those things don't have
to all contradict each other
what do you think about these kinds of
protests are not allowed in many parts
of the world what do you think about
one of the most do you directly
personally painful manifestations of the
first amendment of The People's right to
freedom of speech into protest to say
hateful things
uh you've been at the receiving end
of the worst of it
what what what do you feel about this
particular Freedom that uh that's at the
core of the founding of this country
look I think that you have to take it
away from the text and look at it within
reality let's be real uh would Muslims
be able to protest in front of churches
with guns on a weekly basis in this
country I don't think so so that the
pragmatically speaking there's a
hypocrisy too what's major hypocrisy
major hypocrisy see free speech
is an ideal that is weaponized against
the Muslim Community and against other
communities
and such a hypocritical way you know you
take for example some countries in
Europe you know let's kind of move away
from this and look at the hypocrisy of
uh a place like France where the
caricaturing and the portrayal of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him in
derogatory ways
will be used as the Hallmark of free
speech
but
Muslims that will caricature uh macron
or challenge some of the values of
France the supposed and Shrine values of
France will end up in prison and end up
deported and so here in the United
States there's a great hypocrisy I don't
think that uh places of worship should
have armed protesters in front of them I
think that that poses a security risk I
think that it's not okay
um
and I think that free speech is
weaponized against the Muslim Community
and often is held up as this great value
but really to attain very lowly things
and uh is often to our detriments
yeah just even watching that documentary
it's hard to put into words but somehow
that
does not capture
what may be the founders intended
right what uh what I would see is the
great idea of the freedom of speech
um
I don't know what the solution to that
is
I think taking it outside of words maybe
that requires a community a cultural
pressure to be better
uh
so it's not about the law it's more
about just the cultural pressure what
isn't isn't okay because there's
something deeply wrong about that kind
of hate
or yeah because it was dehumanizing
other people there here in America
that there are Americans
yeah I mean it's it's we have to
interrogate
the foundations of our country when our
country is in such turmoil and such
chaos uh no country in the world has the
mass shootings that we have
no country in the world has
some of the polarization that we have we
have to interrogate that and say what it
is that we're doing wrong that's leading
to that
and I think again that it's it's
reaching a point where it's
unsustainable
um if we don't do better
and try to solve
some of the Rifts right now that exist
in our society
then we're going to end up in you know
in a place where we might we may not be
able to climb out of this
what do you think about you mentioned
the Muslim ban what do you think about
executive order
13769 titled protecting the nation from
foreign terrorist entry into the United
States often referred to as the Muslim
ban or the Trump travel ban it was an
executive order by President Trump that
was in effect from January 27 2017.
for just a few months until March 6 2017
um
what was this executive order and what
was its effect on your life and on the
life of the Muslim Community and just
the life of Americans well it was
disgraceful it was a tactic that was
used
uh you know at the time
um very similar to the whole build the
wall rhetoric
um to to play to a particular political
slogeneering and carrying out those
types of acts against the Muslim
Community
uh you're not going to face uh much
opposition typically in any meaningful
way that would that would be politically
costly
when he rolled it out at the time there
were people in flight on their way to
the United States
that were held in airports around the
country
children elderly people
that were held in these small rooms and
treated awfully before being put back on
a plane and sent to where they were
there were families that had medical
needs that were never able to come
together he
specifically targeted Muslim countries
to play to that idea of a complete ban
of Muslims which he knew was not
feasible
at the time
now personally you know Dallas had the
uh the largest amount the largest number
of uh detainees uh in the airport we
have one of the largest airports in
America and
we took to the airport
and we stayed there for a few days
uh stayed overnight it was one of the
New York Times pictures of the year when
we did our prayer because when we had to
do our prayer it wasn't just Muslims
that came to the airport it was many
people that came to the airport of
different Fates that were outraged by
what they had seen so when we do our
prayer uh there was a protest chant that
you pray we stay
and so the airport had to make room for
us because like a thousand people that
needed to have our five daily prayers
so we would do our prayers in the
airport we waited we continued
until the detainees were freed at least
temporarily unfortunately some elements
of that legislation remained and it was
it was an ongoing uh struggle but look
what I'll say is that those are some of
the more obvious manifestations of
anti-muslim bigotry
but again there's hypocrisy on all sides
of the political aisle here in the
United States
there is islamophobia of different
flavors I think even the term
islamophobia can become contentious
because there are people that attack Us
in different ways and that might not be
as overtly bigoted but nonetheless are
infringing on our rights to be full
American Muslims
and Muslims find themselves in a very
strange political place
where
you've got one side that seemingly wants
to annihilate you
and another side that only accepts you
if you're willing to assimilate
but no one really allows you to be a
full-on American Muslim and so Muslims
find themselves in a very strange place
right now
with all of the political sides with the
political parties where do Muslims sit
politically are they politically engaged
in the function of the United States
where they find this less political as a
community so
Muslims find themselves in an awkward
place politically that's the best way to
put it we are a religious community
and so we don't find ourselves welcomed
by the left which has a hostility
towards religion and most left spaces
and most liberal spaces in general
because it's uh kind of religion has
many conservative elements right so the
Muslim Community is in its nature
conservative for what that's worth right
it's a conservative Community it's a
community that has certain orthodoxies
and practices that
would make it disagreeable in its nature
and its practice to many on the left and
many on the right just see us as a group
of foreigners
and a threat in that regard so
um we find ourselves in this awkward
place there's also the
presence of sort of the pro-israel uh
dominance of both parties the foreign
policy of both parties is detrimental to
Muslims globally
um the securitization of the Muslim
Community and the name of countering by
and extremism unfortunately the Muslim
Community has had both Republican and
Democratic administrations just run over
its rights
so we find ourselves kind of in this
awkward space right we are a religious
community that's also a minority the
racialization of the Muslim Community
sort of robs us of who we are and how we
get to engage them with uh different
platforms and different peoples around
us so we find ourselves in a very
awkward place is there in general a lack
of representation
in places of power
in in politics I think representation is
everything I think that representation
can actually be detrimental sometimes
because you can have people that uh
represent you but that don't actually
represent your your priorities as a
community as a faith community so we
don't want to be tokenized as a
community right we want to be engaged
and engaged fully as Muslims
and be respected as American Muslims you
know I wrote something at the time
actually of Muslim ban I wrote an
article for CNN called I am not your
American Muslim I am not your American
Muslim
because we are not a tool of liberals
against conservatives
nor are we simply to be made out to be
your villain or your victim
where a people of faith
where people that have values where
people that want to see our places of
worship Thrive where people that have
something to offer
to this country to the people around us
of good
But ultimately we want to engage and be
engaged with on the basis of who we
actually are not who you need us to be
right now and that's been the problem
uh that we've had so it's not it's not a
lack of representation as much as a lack
of authentic engagement